allez on va continuer à parler loisirs
avec sylvie l'una bonsoir la directrice
divine tourisme à ego enfin le le point
en tout cas donner des idées de sorties
pour les familles pour l'été dans le
département voilà alors on vient de
parler des bases de loisirs
effectivement de transition parce que je
vais en parler il y en a trois dans le
département et il ya tout un tas de
choses à faire dans chacune d'entre
elles donc la première dont je vais
parler si celle de moisson il ya un
magnifique plan d'eau donc on peut
mettre faire tout un tas d'activités
nautiques et puis il ya aussi de la
plage autour de ce plan d'eau les vtt
les rosalies les quads des pédalos voilà
les ehpad il était là l'eau c'est sympa
je leur ai dit effectivement le pédalo
aussi et donc une deuxième base de
loisirs qui l état et à verneuil celle
de vers nice est vraiment celle dédiée à
la baignade donc c'est comme si on était
la plage on peut se baigner il ya aussi
d'autres activités il ya des midis golf
il ya le tennis ea à la pêche c'est
vraiment comme si on était en vacances
s'il y avait effectivement un temps
propice et puis dernière base de loisirs
d'autres bizarreries acquise elle touche
à coeur pour cela celle de saint quentin
qui est quand même la plus grande île de
france il faut le mentionner
celle là propose beaucoup beaucoup
d'activité toujours le vtt et toutes
celles dont je vous ai déjà parlé mais
en plus on peut faire du segway ce qui
est un petit peu un petit peu nouveau
depuis déjà deux trois ans et puis
également
on peut faire des de la crown heights
qu'est ce que c'est la crown heights et
de l'accrobranche de nuit tout
simplement la chauve-souris et puis on
vole dans les airs et voilà et c'est une
activité un petit peu insolite alors au
tri des directions ça sert d'école la
ferme de gally et alors la ferme de
gally qui propose cette année plusieurs
labyrinthe comme vous le savez c'est
l'année le nôtre c'est les 400 ans de la
naissance de lenôtre effectivement
gallier a suivi tout ça en mettant en
place un labyrinthe
sur le modèle de celui qui avait été
conçu à versailles et puis il ya
d'autres labyrinthe un deuxième de maïs
qui est un labyrinthe des fragrances et
d'essence et qui lui est de maïs
circulaire donc on peut se perdre dans
les dédales du de ce champ de maïs
improvisé et le troisième c'est celui
plus pour les enfants c'est le
labyrinthe de nono l'escargot et là on
découvre les petites bêtes de nos
jardins dans ce labyrinthe avec un petit
des petites énigmes c'est très sympa le
labyrinthe par contre ça a bien poussé
mais voilà direction versailles la salle
du jeu de paume avant l' intérieur
mythique et là un jeu de fausses zaouit
ait été signé le serment du jeu de paume
le 20 juin 1789 et on peut visiter cette
salle qui n'est pas ouverte tout le
temps pendant les vacances elle sera
ouverte du mardi au samedi de 14 à 18
heures avec des visites guidées
et donc qu'ils sont réservables auprès
de l'office de tourisme de versailles et
puis pour les groupes on appelle quand
on vous voit là on reste à versailles
les jardins musicaux dans les jardins
musicaux qu'est ce qui va se passer
voilà le perçage les petits personnages
de la bande des six des totally spies
va animer les jardins musicaux avec alex
sam et clover qui vont vous proposer des
petites eni et dans ces jardins musicaux
effectivement on va les retrouver et
tout ça est animée pour pour les jeunes
mais aussi pour l'épauler moi je n'ai
pas quitté versailles on va dire
direction rambouillet et en juillet bien
sûr il ya la bergerie nationale c'est 50
dont on parle très simple en est la
bergerie nationale qu'on soit beaucoup
beaucoup d'événements pour les enfants
et pendant les vacances ce sont les a ni
vacances alors on sait qu'on peut y
retrouver des animaux de la ferme à la
bergerie nationale on peut regarder
comment on s'en occupe mais aussi on
peut participer à des différents
ateliers le quai de tonte
et tout un tas d'autres
pendant les vacances qui sont assez
amusantes à découvrir maintenant on va
les directions pour marly en voyage avec
vous un oui bah fait le tour dont les
parts de fonction on va aller on va
aller à la rencontre d'un château qui
est très mignon dit joyeux jamais fait
ça le château de monte-cristo est oui
alors le château de monte-cristo qu'est
ce qu'il a de particulier c'est que
c'était la maison d'alexandre dumas donc
on peut y pratiquer des visites
théâtralisées c'est la façon de
découvrir ce petit château de façon
particulière
et donc on est nette avec des comédiens
qui vous font revivre la vie d'alexandre
dumas et donc c'est un bon moyen de se
plonger dans le temps et de découvrir un
peu pas comme d'habitude puisque quand
on y va tout seul il n'y a pas tout ça
donc faut profiter des vacances pour le
voir de cette façon et c'est vraiment un
vrai coup de coeur on voit les images à
ceux de ce petit château style
renaissance qui est absolument
merveilleux dans un écrin de verdure en
plus à port-marly enfin bon moi j'aime
beaucoup ça je mettrai ça allait bien
aller direction tout près de chez nous
la maintenons le prêt de saint quentin
le parc naturel la haute vallée de
chevreuse alors le parc naturel de la
haute vallée de chevreuse propose tout
un tas de visite particulière pendant
les vacances
la visite du château de la madeleine qui
est la maison du parc mais aussi la
visite de la ville de montfort l'amaury
qui est une petite ville médiévale
merveilleuse qui a rejoint le parc
depuis l'année dernière puisque le parc
s'est étendu il ya beaucoup de communes
maintenant donc d'état de visite que
vous propose de vous que vous propose le
parc de la haute vallée de chevreuse qui
est un petit un petit joyau si ce parc
on a l'impression d'être très très loin
de paris il ya la campagne il ya des
jolies château et est donc ça nous
permet d'être très loin de chez nous
tout en étant très près tout à fait
c'est très mignon et dernière petite
information dans les idées sorties les
îliens ont fait leur cinéma c'est ça
alors ça c'est plus pour la fin des
vacances puisque ça commence le 20 août
et que ça finit le 7 septembre et donc
on pourra découvrir du cinéma en plein
air et ses 24 communes qui propose cette
activité nocturne donc avec tout un tas
de films alors c'est des films qui sont
anciens mais aussi aux récents donc on a
dans les films en cire indiana jones
jumanji alors vous imaginez sur grand
écran ce que ça peu et revenir et en
plein air en plus et on a des films plus
récents comme tintin et le secret de la
licorne par exemple donc ça c'est des
bons moments et c'est tout le programme
est à découvrir sur le nouveau site que
nous avons mis en ligne de 13 juin qui
est le guide de sortie et donc on peut
trouver toutes ces animations dont on
vient de parler les lieux où sont
diffusés ces filles absolument sur ce
site dit de sortie en espérant qu'il
fasse beau ça bonjour les vacances on va
se dire ça y est c'est parti le beau
temps est là il pas merci beaucoup
eh ben on était à vous merci beaucoup